- Hello, hello everyone.
Welcome and thank you so much for coming.
I'm Stephen Pitti.
I'm a professor of history
in American Studies
and ethnicity, race, and migration,
and the director of the
Center for the Study
of Race, Indigeneity, and
Transnational Migration.
It's great to see everyone
here today on Election Day.
Hope you all, those of
you who can, have voted.
Really, really thrilled
to welcome back to campus
Monica Muñoz Martinez,
the Stanley J. Bernstein
assistant professor
of American Studies at Brown University.
Monica was named last year
an Andrew Carnegie Fellow
as one of, quote, the country's
most creative thinkers,
undertaking quote, research on challenges
to democracy and international order.
A major honor and a
certainly a fitting one,
given the work that she does.
Monica received her PhD in
American Studies here at Yale,
and at Brown, she offers
courses on Latinx studies,
immigration, histories of violence,
histories of policing,
and public memory in
United States history.
Her remarkable first book, The
Injustice Never Leaves You:
Anti-Mexican Violence in the United States
was just published by
Harvard University Press
in September of 2018.
Recommend it to all of you.
There are a number of students in the room
who already had the chance to read it.
And she'll be discussing
that project here today.
Monica Martinez is also
the primary investigator
for Mapping Violence, a
digital project at Brown
that documents histories of
racial violence in Texas.
She's also a founding member
of the nonprofit organization
Refusing to Forget,
an organization that calls
for a public reckoning
with racial violence in Texas.
That team developed an
award-winning exhibit
for the Bullock Texas State History Museum
that marked the first
time in Texas history
that a cultural institution acknowledged
Texas's state responsibility
for a period of racial
terror in the 20th century.
Monica has also helped to
secure state historical markers
along the US-Mexico border,
commemorating racial violence in Texas,
and that has kept her very busy.
Indeed up until just hours
ago, you were busy with this,
with a ceremonial unveiling,
and other types of work.
Please join me in welcoming
Monica Martinez back to Yale.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Steve.
I'm so happy to be here
with you in New Haven.
Happy voting election day.
I had another outfit planned
for today from Joe's Bakery.
It was a t-shirt called
eat tacos and vote.
And I had a fabulous
crushed blue velvet blazer
that I bought several years ago
and never had a reason to wear it.
And then Oprah stole my look.
She wore it before I did.
And I called my mom, and she said,
well you can't you know who
wore it best with Oprah, Monica.
(laughing)
So instead I'm wearing
a skirt that I bought
when I was on the job market.
But I wanted to dress for
the occasion for the day,
but also for coming back to New
Haven and to Yale University
and to be with faculty and colleagues
that helped me write this
book, and planted the seeds
not only for The Injustice
Never Leaves You,
but also for the public work
that helped me develop a praxis.
And it also feels in many ways
like I'm having the opportunity
to continue a conversation
and to help think through some questions
that I still have about the best way
to make histories of
racial violence public.
I've had, as Steve was
saying, an opportunity
to present my work in
different communities
in Texas and across the country,
but also to participate
in public projects,
and I still have questions
about the responsible ways
for bringing these
histories to the public,
and for engaging different communities
in conversations about
histories of racial violence,
and how to connect
truthfully with the past.
So I'm so thankful for the
invitation to come back.
I'm also honored to
participate in celebrating
20 years of ethnicity race
and migration at Yale,
and I'm so thankful to the faculty
and the students in this room
that helped to make it possible
to organize and mobilize, to
build and dream of the center.
It's really inspiring.
And I'm so thankful also for Nandi,
for the work that she did
to help bring me here.
So I'm gonna do my best to
stay still for the camera,
and share a bit with you from the book.
I want to give a quick overview
of just some of the interventions
that the book makes,
and that I think has helped
lead to the reception the good reception
that the book has received.
So to give people just a broader
sense of the interventions,
I'll actually read a section of the book
to help introduce some of
the, a quick case study,
and to also give people
a sense of the methods
and the questions that
I engage in the book.
And then after that,
I'm gonna talk through
some of the problems and challenges
with actually bringing
about a public reckoning
and dialogue about this
history of racial violence.
So I also, can I get a sense
of how many people in the
room have read the book?
That's a good number, okay.
And how many of you know nothing about
history of anti-Mexican violence in Texas?
Okay, alright, so we've
got a range of audience.
I just wanted to get a sense.
So just very broadly,
my book The Injustice Never Leaves You
grapples with a period
of anti-Mexican violence
in Texas in the early 20th century.
it was a period between 1910 and 1920
that was a reign of
terror, state sanctioned.
It was a reign of terror
enacted by a coalition of Texas Rangers,
the state police officers in Texas,
local law enforcement officers,
Anglo vigilantes, and US soldiers.
And so it's striking,
the parallels that I see
from 100 years ago and today,
in terms of the culture
of anti-Mexican violence.
So in the early 20th century,
there was a, politicians, the
media, and local residents
criminalized ethnic Mexicans as bandits,
as threats to the nation,
as threats to Anglos more specifically,
and also as threats to Anglo capitalism.
And so you saw a period of,
in which there were calls to increase
the police presence on the border.
In 1914, the government
responded by sending
over 100,000 US troops to the border.
And so the criminalization of
ethnic Mexicans in this period
was answered by the brutal policing
of this intersection regime
of law enforcement officers, soldiers,
and Anglo vigilantes.
And one of the tensions in the book
is that in this period
there was an effort to
justify the violence,
and that led to public
understandings in this period
of anti-Mexican violence
actually being progress.
And so one of the tensions in the book
is that on the one hand,
there have been calls for over 100 years
by people who live in the borderlands,
people from this era, who sought justice,
and from generation to
generation passed down an effort
to try to change public understandings
of this period of racial violence.
But that's in tension with
a broad national forgetting
of this period of anti-Mexican violence.
And so it's estimated
that between 1910 and 1920
that hundreds of ethnic Mexicans
were murdered by these agents,
and that those victims included
American citizens of Mexican descent,
people that were racialized as Mexican,
as foreign others, as criminal threats,
and Mexican nationals
that were living in
Texas during this period.
And so a good number of the people
that had moved into South Texas
in this period were refugees
fleeing the violence of
the Mexican Revolution.
And so in this period,
most people publicly have forgotten
these calls for violence, and
this period of racial terror.
And one of the interventions
that I make in the book
is not only to document
the kinds of violence,
the widespread violence,
but also to document the ways in which
this kind of violence
was institutionalized.
And so for historians of the borderlands,
other historians that have
written about this period of violence,
there's a long tradition of historians,
starting from the early 20th century
with Walter Prescott Webb,
that really created and institutionalized
not only in the field of history,
but also in public history,
a progress narrative.
That Mexicans are a
violent group of people,
that they are racially inferior,
that they have dirty water,
trough water for blood,
and that Texas Ranger brutality
at the hands of Texas Rangers
of state police officers
was actually progress.
It secured the border for Anglo capital,
and for Anglo Americans.
But one of the ways in which I think
that the borderlands historians
that have returned to this period
to actually expose the brutality
and expose the murders of people,
the denial of due process
for ethnic Mexicans in this region
is that historians have
also fallen into this trap
of looking at this
period as ending in 1920.
And so in 1919, J.T. Canales,
who was a state representative
from Brownsville,
he helped to lead an investigation
into the Texas Rangers.
And so some of the acts of
brutality become so egregious,
namely the Porvenir
massacre in January 1918.
It was the the massacre of 15 men and boys
who were in the custody of Texas Rangers.
This community was interrupted
by a group of Texas Rangers,
local ranching family, local ranchers,
and they were supported
by a US cavalry troop.
And in the middle of the night,
this community was awoken,
taken from their homes,
and this group of 15 men
and boys was executed.
And so that event caused,
sort of put a spotlight
on the kinds of brutality
that had been occurring over the decade.
And in 1919, there was an investigation
into the Texas Rangers,
which led to weeks of investigations.
But as a result of the crimes
that were brought to light
from that investigation,
the Texas Ranger force
was reduced in number.
So part of the escalation
of policing in this period
took the form of the the
Texas state police force
growing dramatically from under
less than 100 Texas Rangers in 1914,
by 1919 there was 1,350
Texas Rangers approximately.
And so one of the ways
that the state responded
to these kinds of acts of
brutality being exposed
was to reduce the numbers of
the Texas Rangers drastically.
And so they reduced the force
from over 1,300 to less than 75.
And so even for historians
that have returned to this period
to recover in this period of violence,
they've sort of understood
the Canales Investigation
as leading to the end,
the decline of this kind of brutality.
And so part of the work that I've done
is to trace the movement
of some of these Texas
Rangers and police officers
to track the kinds of violence
that they participated in
different parts of the state.
But also to note that and
to highlight quite clearly
that firing somebody from
the Texas Ranger Police Force
is not justice for murder,
and that in fact the Texas Rangers,
some of the most, with
the bloodiest records,
were released from the force
just before the investigation began.
And so there were crimes
that were documented
that were never heard
before the committee.
But in many cases like the Texas Rangers
that participated in
the Porvenir massacre,
some of them that were released
went on to become sheriffs to
work in local law enforcement,
and some of them actually returned
back to the Texas Ranger
force years later.
And so I've tried to, in this project
expose the longer roots of
this period of violence,
and how it shaped institutions of policing
and cultures of policing,
and to raise concerns
about the periodization
of this period of violence ending in 1920.
And that's, you know, one of
the other parts of this project
was to also show the ways
in which policing culture
shapes societies more broadly.
And so in understandings of
racial violence in US history,
most often people think
about mob violence,
so think about lynchings.
And in the history in Texas,
there's not only a deep
history of lynching,
so the NAACP ranked
Texas third in the nation
for having the highest
numbers of lynchings,
just behind Georgia and Mississippi,
for the numbers of anti-black lynchings.
In Texas between 1848 and 1928,
Texans lynched over 200 ethnic Mexicans.
And so there is a deep
culture of mob violence,
but some of the work that I do
is to actually show the ways
in which the police themselves
were agents of racial terror,
practicing extralegal forms of violence,
and targeting multiple
racial and ethnic groups.
And so one of the the projects
that I developed after I left Yale
was to study the role of the Texas Rangers
in intimidating NAACP
chapters across the state,
and participating in mob violence
by leaving prisoners unarmed.
And so part of the work
too is trying to expose
how these histories of racial violence
are deeply interconnected.
In a place like Texas so you can map
how the state is acting to
create this reign of terror.
But for too long, violence
at the hands of police
has been shielded in a
cloak of legal authority.
And in large part that's
because of the reliance
of early historians like
Walter Prescott Webb
on the use of Texas Ranger records,
and seeing what Rangers
were producing as truth.
And so I wanna read,
so I'll do a little, a
reading from the book
before moving on to two other points
about the the interventions of the book.
So I open with, for people
who are not from Texas,
a scene from Brownsville
at the southernmost point of the state.
Brownsville borders Matamoros,
you can see it there.
And here's a picture from
Robert Runyon's collection,
an aerial photograph
of the US-Mexico border
in the 19-teens.
the community on the south,
just south of the border is Matamoros,
and north is Brownsville.
And so you get the sense
of how intimately connected
these communities were.
People would live on one side of the river
and owned a business on the other side.
People moved fluidly.
And so the calls to militarize
the border in this era
really was trying to create
a divide between communities.
And so that was something
that new Anglo settlers
that arrived in South Texas
in the early 20th century
wanted to create an international border
that felt like a division,
rather than just a river.
So I open the book with the
story of Florencio Garcia.
It was an otherwise ordinary
day in early April 1918,
but Miguel Garcia, a Mexican
national living in Texas,
was growing concerned.
His son Florencio, 25 years old,
had not yet returned home
from his job as a cattle
herder in Cameron County.
Garcia started walking through town
asking relatives, friends, neighbors,
and eventually even the county attorney
and local law enforcement officers
if they had seen Florencio.
Days passed without news.
Then someone told Garcia
that Texas Rangers
had arrested Florencio
over a week earlier,
on April 5th, just south of Brownsville.
Garcia knew that when
ethnic Mexicans disappeared
after being arrested,
the prisoners remains were often found
hidden in the grove of mesquite trees
in the rural Texas landscape.
This grim news prompted Garcia
to start searching the
brush in the countryside
for his son's remains.
Miguel Garcia repeatedly asked for help
from local authorities.
Oscar Dancy, the Cameron County Attorney,
remembered Garcia's persistence.
The old man, the father of
the boy, was at my office.
He was at my office two or three times,
and my residence once.
Weeks later, local residents
found human remains
outside of Brownsville, Dancy remembered.
We found the bones of a human being.
We found a pair of pants and a jumper,
and as I recollect it, a
shirt, black hair, and a hat.
A light Texas cowboy Stetson hat.
And he added that there were
bullet holes noticed in the
jacket, two perhaps three.
The clothing matched the description
Miguel Garcia had previously provided,
and the investigation suggested
that the body had been shot
in the back three times.
The remains consisted only of clothes,
a skull with a tuft of hair,
and bones scattered as far as 300 yards,
likely by coyotes or buzzards.
Garcia arrived at the scene,
and identified the
shoes, hat, and clothing
as belonging to Florencio.
The father pulled a
monographed handkerchief
out of the jacket they had discovered,
and verified that it was his son's.
So the story of Miguel Garcia
looking for his father,
I decided to write about this
to open the book for a few reasons.
What ended up playing out,
what I ended up finding in the archives,
thanks to the investigations
by the Mexican Consulate
that investigated this case,
was that there were witnesses
to Florencio being in the
custody of the state police.
There were witnesses that found him,
that saw him being held
in a jail, county jail.
And then there were witnesses
that saw him leaving the county jail
in the custody of Texas Rangers.
And so from this account,
Miguel Garcia pressured local authorities
to investigate the murder of his son.
And he also pressured local authorities
to offer to write a death
certificate for his son.
And so this became crucially
important in the archives
for me being able to tell the history,
not only of the father's
efforts, of the family's efforts,
but to find a document that confirmed
that Florencio Garcia died.
And so this is an important find.
You know, it includes information,
biographical information about Florencio,
his date of birth, for example,
his occupation as a cattle herder,
the birthplace, his birthplace,
but also the names of his parents.
We don't have here access
to the name of his wife,
but we have information
about who testified and
identified the body.
It was Miguel Garcia.
We also have information here
about the date of his burial.
So we know that his family
did bury the remains of Florencio.
But we also see an interesting note here
where the coroner actually
had to amend the document.
And so he had to amend the primary source,
because of the conditions
under which the body was found.
And so he didn't have
information about when he died,
he didn't have information, you know,
he couldn't say the last
I saw him or her alive
was on this date.
And so he actually scratched
through the text on the form,
and said that I attended,
that I found the identified remains,
and the death occurred on unknown date.
And so with this interesting
moment in the archives
where you see that this body
that the remains of Florencio
is literally falling out of the ways
in which a coroner would traditionally
write one of these documents.
And of course here, it
must have been unsettling
for the family to see that the
cause of death was unknown,
especially given that they found,
and the investigation found,
that there were bullet holes
in the back of the jacket.
But because the remains
had been so far decomposed,
the coroner, I'm guessing,
is one of the reasons that they use to not
include that that the cause of death
was being shot or murdered.
But one of the reasons why this document
is also so important
is that it directly
contrasts and undermines
the efforts by the Texas Rangers
that participated in arresting Florencio,
and that had been identified
as having him in his custody
when he was last seen alive.
They actually wrote and testified
that they had released Florencio,
that they caused him no harm,
and that actually that he had been seen
across the border in Matamoros.
And that perhaps he just didn't want,
he wanted to abandon his family.
And so despite this death
certificate being written,
despite Florencio being
buried by his family,
there's not only,
the Texas Rangers continued to deny
any involvement in his death.
But with this death certificate in hand,
Florencio Garcia's family was able to have
the three Texas Rangers arrested.
They were released on bond
and placed back into custody
of their, the supervision of the captain
that they worked under,
and a grand jury decided not
to indict the Texas Rangers.
And so there's no prosecution
of the Texas Rangers,
but we do have this death certificate,
and for the estimates
that hundreds of ethnic
Mexicans died in this period
is an estimate because part
of the acts of violence
was that there was no consistent effort
to record the deaths.
And so we have access to
the writings of journalists
who wrote articles about these deaths,
we have access to some
of these rare documents,
like these death certificates,
Access to Mexican consulate records,
so in this case because
Florencio was a Mexican national,
the Mexican consul could be involved
in calling for an investigation,
and in large part, that's what led to
at least the arrest of the Texas Rangers,
and the pressure to have this
death certificate issued.
But of course, the grand jury was not
under the control of the Mexican consul
or the requests of the father,
and so there's no prosecution
of the Texas Rangers here.
And the the effort to undermine
the pleas and the calls for justice
that we see not only in the effort,
the several attempts of Miguel Garcia
to go and ask the county attorney
for help in finding his son,
and then asking for the death
certificates to be issued,
then calling for the arrest of his son,
we see that all disavowed by the state,
by the Texas Ranger Captain Stevens,
who testified in the Gonzalez
investigation in 1919.
And he in his report disputed
that Florencio Garcia even died.
So here we see in the questions,
did you interrogate the men
and investigate the facts?
And did you decide in your own mind
whether or not they had
anything to do with the death?
If he is dead?
He's being interviewed
here by the attorneys
representing the state.
And Stevens replies,
I investigated the statements they made,
and I went to Brownsville,
and I heard through a Mexican
that this man was seen across the river.
After they turned him loose?
Yes, after they turned him loose.
I spoke to deputy sheriff
who made the investigation,
and he stated that he did not think
that this was the body of Garcia,
that those bones had been
there quite a long time.
Right so again, they're also disputing
the identification of the son's remains.
You don't know that Florencio Garcia
had a reputation of being
a notorious cow thief
on the other side of the river.
I heard this after the investigation.
And that there was cooperation
with the authorities.
And so the the investigation goes on.
But in this document, we
see that Florencio Garcia,
they're still denying that he died,
they're still denying the
identification of him,
and you also see the
criminalization of the dead, right.
And do you know, and
you don't know, right,
that he was a notorious cow thief.
So this pattern in 1918
gives us just a glimpse
into the other cases.
In this case, we actually
have a name of the victim,
but there's many others that
we don't have the names of.
And so this was, this case and others
are important for also putting on display
and exposing the ways in
which the state authorities
participated in justifying violence,
covering crimes, and
criminalizing the dead.
And that is something that in,
and even in the public mainstream accounts
of this period that celebrated violence
or that justified or
mitigated the violence,
they often cast blame on rogue agents.
And so the work that I did in the book
is also to expose the roles
of governors, US Congressmen,
that called for violence and said things,
like Congressman Hudspeth said,
"I will lead a mob against
them, those bandits.
"You've got to shoot
them when you see them."
Right, so this is also the namesake
of Hudspeth County in West Texas,
so who also then went on in 1924
to write into legislation
a one million dollar rider
to the Immigration Act of 1924
to build the Border Patrol.
So Kelley Lydell Adnandis
has done excellent work
in tracing the roots of the
development of the Border Patrol
being built by former Texas Rangers.
But men like Hudspeth,
who called for violence
and justified even mob violence,
imagined a federal force built-in
like of the Texas Rangers.
So enough about the state.
The other sort of key departure in my book
is really utilizing
feminist research methods.
And so in the period of the
examinations of this violence,
the work before had primarily focused
on conflict between men,
Anglo men and Mexican men.
And the work that I did,
being really inspired by my training
in gender and sexuality studies
and women and gender studies,
But also in critical analysis
of the work of women and mothers
in calling out injustice in Latin America
throughout the 20th century,
and most recently in the 1980s
and 90s and through today.
I was really captivated
by what it meant to study
and document as a historian
what it was like to live
in a reign of terror.
And so that requires that
we examine the aftermath.
And a lot of the the
good foundational work
in borderlands history has contributed to
collecting the names of people who died,
you know, a body count.
But if we think about
trying to get a glimpse
into how terror shaped daily life,
it requires us to ask what happened
after Florencio Garcia was buried.
And in that case, I don't
have any more information
into where the family
moved, where they left,
but other signal cases that
I selected for the book
gave us access to the longer legacy
that these acts of violence had
in shaping generations of families,
but also shaping communities
for over a century.
And this is also building on the work,
like other historians
like Kidada Williams,
who insist that historians have to do
more than just study the violence
events of racial violence.
So this has helped to really send her
the work of women, and also
provide a gendered understanding
of these kind, the dynamics
of racial violence.
And what I found was that in erasing
or forgetting what happened
in the aftermath of violence
we have foreclosed the
possibilities of exposing
the methods that were
available for seeking justice
for the surviving relatives.
So finding, you know, having,
pushing for an investigation,
pushing for a death certificate.
But I also found the work
of widows and children
who filed legislation lawsuits
against the US government.
Namely Mexican nationals
that sought to hold the state accountable
for the murder of their
husbands or their children.
And so this was really an
important legal archive
to stumble into, because it gave us access
to what happened for Mexican nationals,
what were the possibilities
when local courts fail to prosecute.
And so in some cases,
there were families who did receive
indemnities from the US government
for either the failure of the state
to prosecute mob participants
or for the direct
involvement of US soldiers
or law enforcement agents
like the Texas Rangers
in the murder of their children.
But you know, I also was really attentive
to the the burden that
these families had to carry
in testifying repeatedly
throughout the investigations
to Mexican consuls, to US
consuls, to county officials,
and thinking through the dynamics
of having to attend to the
violence of on the body
in an effort to seek justice.
And so that introduced me to
not just the work of women
in in seeking justice
immediately in the aftermath,
but it also introduced me to families
who had been connected by
this period of violence
by a broadly felt injustice.
And so it was an injustice,
not just from learning the histories
and learning about the violence
the violent acts themselves,
learning that people weren't prosecuted
in this period of violence,
but also learning that
this period of violence
had been disavowed by the state,
or erased or silenced or celebrated.
And so thinking about injustice
here, it's multifaceted.
So it's the injustice of what
took place in the 19-teens,
but then it's also the continued
injustices that these families carried.
And so one person described this to me as,
Norma Longoria Rodriguez is
one of the leading Texas residents
who I interviewed about the double murder
of her grandfather and great-grandfather,
Jesus Bazan and Antonio Longoria.
They were murdered by a
posse of a Texas Ranger
and two civilians, Paul
West and William Sterling.
William Sterling went on later
to lead the Texas Ranger force.
But in September 1915, her
grandfather and great-grandfather
visited a Texas Ranger
a camp in South Texas
in Hidalgo County to report
that they had been robbed.
And so they wanted to report
that they had had horses stolen.
In the case that the people
that stole these horses
were later arrested,
the family didn't want these horses
in the custody of these
men to then bring suspicion
of them supporting banditry.
And in this era even being suspected
or just called being
suspected of banditry,
or sympathizing with bandits,
was a license to kill.
And so on the way home, Jesus
Bazan and Antonio Longoria,
you know, it's reported,
witnesses later reported,
that they mounted their horses
to return back to their ranch,
and when they had reached
about 300 yards away
from the ranger campsite,
these three men loaded
into a Model T Ford,
drove to the men, and shot
them both in the back.
So part of the devastating
history of this account
was not only the brutality
of the cold-blooded murder,
but that also that Texas
Ranger Captain Harry Ransom
ordered the witnesses,
the laborers on the ranch,
not to bury the remains.
Not to tend to the remains,
but also not to bury the remains.
And so this was an extreme act
of disrespect and intimidation.
And so a few days passed
before friends of Bazan and Longoria
took the risk and actually
buried the remains.
But when Norma Longoria
Rodriguez learned of this story,
it really interrupted her life,
and it filled her with a sense of grief,
and it left her with unanswered questions.
So she turned to history.
She visited local libraries
to read history books
about this period of violence.
She wanted to, when she heard
that a Texas Ranger had participated,
it disrupted all of her
understandings of the Rangers.
You know, these were the
Lone Ranger and Chuck Norris,
the heroes that she had
grown up idolizing in school.
And so she went to the history books
to try to learn more about
this period of violence.
And she found some books,
but for the most part,
she had more questions.
And so she also tried to
turn to local archives,
state archives, she went to Austin
to look at the Texas Ranger reports,
she read through microfilm
of local newspapers,
trying to find some
discussion of this case,
and she didn't find anything.
She didn't find a death certificate
for Jesus Bazan and Antonio Longoria.
And so despite dedicating
weekends and vacations
to searching state archives
for public records,
she didn't find these records.
And so instead she took on the task
of documenting her family history.
And so I actually found
Norma Longoria Rodriguez.
Steve Pitti in the middle
of my dissertation research
forwarded me an email
because she had published an essay
called Silence of the Heart,
which gave a history of her grandmother's,
and her great-grandmother,
Epigmenia Bazan and Antonia Longoria,
that had to live in the wake of violence.
And so she wrote a history
of her grandmother and great-grandmother,
and gave an account of the double murder,
and she published it in a local,
in a digital publication
called Somos Primos.
And so I visited her,
I conducted an oral history
with her for about two hours,
and then she brought out a piece of,
you know I thought the interview was done,
so I was packing up my stuff,
and then she brings out a
piece of pie and some iced tea,
and then she brings out photographs,
and then she brings out pictures,
oh that's the same thing.
She brings put photographs
(laughs) and maps,
and a teaching certificate
of Antonio Longoria's,
and a letter that describes him
as the Hidalgo County Commissioner.
And so she started to bring me documents
that proved that the two men had lived.
And she showed me photographs
of the gravestones.
And then she brought out documents
that gave me access to who her grandmother
and great-grandmother were.
And she told me stories
about Antonia Longoria,
who she referred to as
(speaks foreign language),
you know, her grandmother.
Told me about the baked
goods that she made,
told me about how they leased out land,
and just this weekend
I learned about a grove of peach trees
that they had on the ranch
that died after the double murder,
because the family couldn't sustain
all of the work on the ranch.
But when I asked her about this work
and a sentiment of loss that had remained,
she explained it's an injustice,
it never leaves you, it's inherited loss.
And the title of the book,
The Injustice Never Leaves You,
comes from that interview,
and it's inspired by the questions
that Norma Longoria
Rodriguez prompted me to ask
that other historians had
not prompted me to ask.
Historians are objective, stay removed,
this is not the field of emotions.
And one of the unanswered questions
that has stayed with me
is that she wished that
she had had the opportunity
to ask one of the witnesses
before they passed
if her grandfather and
great-grandfather died quickly.
Did they have a fast death?
Or did they suffer?
You know, and that is
such a human question.
You know, she connected intimately
with this grandfather
and great-grandfather
who she never knew,
and more than just wanting to know
the who, what, where, when, and why,
what were the motives, who
were the Texas Rangers,
when did it happen,
she was really lingering
in those last moments,
when Captain Ransom ordered people
not to tend to the
bodies, were they alive?
You know?
Those are the questions that she has,
and those are the questions
that she's continued to ask,
but also, she's been committed
to making the history public.
And I remember sitting in Joanne
Meyerowitz's office in HGS,
and talking about Norma
Longoria Rodriguez,
and the Alvarados that I had met,
and saying these, they are
a part of this history.
The history did not end in 1918
when the massacre happened.
And they were making history,
they were writing their own history.
And so this is coming from the archive
of Norma Longoria Rodriguez.
This is a photograph of his Jesus Bazan.
This was on display in the Bullock Museum.
The Bullock Museum pulls from archives
like the Library of Congress,
the Autry Museum in L.A.,
the Texas State Archives,
but they didn't know Jesus Bazan,
and they didn't have a picture of him.
And they also didn't have
this stunning photograph
of Epigmenia Bazan, here she
is, and her granddaughters.
This is Eloisa, you know,
surrounded by the plants
and with the bird in the corner.
I just love this photograph,
and if I could be this,
if I could just pose
like that all the time.
But this was a photograph
that Christine Molis,
her mother Melba Coody had in their home
that they donated or lent
to the Bullock Museum
to have on display.
And they also had this photograph
of Antonio Longoria and Antonia Longoria,
and the inscription on the
back is really beautiful.
It's written to their friends,
who they call their
brothers, right, you know,
the familial connection here,
and so this was taken in 1895.
And so these are the kinds of documents
that the families had preserved,
they had participated in
preserving an archive,
and pulling together a
collection of documents.
But she also participated
in writing history.
The vernacular history making
is the concept that I pulled from.
It was Joanne, she said it's
vernacular history making,
so there it is, it's in the book.
So she published a piece most recently
in La Voz de Esperanza, it comes
out of the Esperanza Center
in San Antonio, Texas.
And so she wrote a lyrical
(speaks foreign language)
to her cousin, and his
name is Ricardo Martinez,
and he helped to restore the homestead
of Antonio Longoria and Antonia Longoria,
and so the oral histories
that Norma Longoria Rodriguez
helped to record of the
accounts of the children
that were in the house
the day that these men
came to take horses.
He's preserved for example
like the same window
that they looked out of
and described in their oral histories
is still in the home that he's preserved.
So this is the kind of
vernacular history making
that I write about in the book
as being an important political,
an important historical contribution,
but also speaking back to the tradition
that celebrates the Texas Rangers
or that celebrates this
period of racial violence.
But that's a tall task
because we also remember
that Walter Prescott Webb
wrote, published his
first canonical account
of the Texas Rangers in 1935,
when he described
indigenous people as savages
and Mexicans as having
dirty water for blood.
And that became inscribed
in in Texas history,
because he helped to build
public history in Texas.
And so the book coming out in 1935
was influential in the celebrations
of the Texas centennial in Texas.
So Texans celebrate Texas independence,
and so in 1936, he helped to install
over 1,000 monuments
across the state of Texas,
and to inspire exhibitions
at the Texas Centennial
like the Junior Rangers with the pledge,
like a good Ranger, I'll
be brave, honest, obedient,
and always keep my eyes out for danger.
And so this is actually
a pledge that students,
that young generations can still take.
It's sponsored by the
Texas Ranger History Museum
in Waco, Texas.
But of course, generations
have also been brought up
watching The Lone Ranger
and Walker Texas Ranger,
and so the work that
families and descendants
have had to take on in
trying to commemorate
these histories of racial violence,
or speaking back to myths
that have been ingrained
in public understandings of the past.
And so I, a little bit lost for time,
because I don't have a clock.
What time?
Okay, so here we go.
So I'm gonna wrap up just by showing,
okay, so then there's also
the baseball Texas Rangers,
I don't know if any of
you are Rangers fans.
I mean yeah, so there's
that guy, there's Bush.
But then there's this.
(audience laughing)
I have another one,
I wish that I had one with his mother
with the former first lady,
because it's really charming, actually,
she looks really cute in a baseball cap.
But is also the Waco Texas
Ranger History Museum,
and I write a review of
the museum in my book,
and I was saying earlier that I thought,
you know, after I was reading it,
like wow that was really tough.
And then I visited the museum
again, just a week ago,
and I found even more,
that I could have really amped
it up, actually, I think.
There's a lot of work that we have to do
in having a truthful
accounting of the past,
encouraging cultural
institutions across the state
to participate in a truthful
accounting of the past,
and there are some institutions,
not just this but across the state,
that actually have very,
that have racist depictions of the past.
And I don't use that word lightly.
But in working with
descendants of racial violence,
and this group that I helped to start
called Refusing to Forget,
we started organizing in 2013
to pull together public commemorations,
because we recognize that
despite the dozens of books
that documented this
period of racial violence,
those academic, the
progress that we had made
in professional conversations
and understandings of history,
had not changed public
understandings of the past.
And so we were thinking about
having an exhibit at UT-Austin
sponsored by the Center for
Mexican-American Studies,
and we were thinking of raising funds
for one monument or marker,
some sort of statue,
artist installation.
And when we talked to
people like Norma Longoria,
when we had our first organizing meeting,
I invited descendants like
Norma Longoria Rodriguez
and the Alvarados,
who are descendants of
the Porvenir massacre,
and they very adamantly said,
and what is the state gonna do?
So the peak of violence occurred in 2015,
we had been planning for 2015,
and they said, "and what
is the state gonna do?"
Because we have been memorializing
these histories on our own,
we have been documenting them on our own,
we have our own events,
what is it gonna take for the state
to finally acknowledge its role
in this period of violence?
And so it shifted our whole,
or all of our strategies,
and so we utilized the Undertold
Marker program in Texas,
which is actually a phenomenal program.
Since 2006, they have unveiled
over 100 markers across the state,
that tell undertold histories of Texas.
And so what it does is
it creates an opportunity
for anybody in Texas and any historian
to submit an application
for an undertold marker,
and it does not require
a county to nominate,
to sponsor the application.
And so in some of the cases
of episodes of racial violence
that I have documented,
the counties are opposed to
having a marker like this.
And so when you submit
it directly to the state,
the state can approve or
disapprove the application.
I actually had to apply
for this one three times.
But we just unveiled it on Saturday.
And so it was tremendous.
We had 175 people attended
the unveiling ceremony.
We had descendants
participated, we had a blessing,
and it was incredible.
But we had like a three-day
public history extravaganza,
and so we had a conference that day,
and this is here Melba Coody,
and Norma Longoria Rodriguez,
and Ricardo Martinez,
and they spoke about their own
work preserving the history,
how they learned the history,
and then what they did
to try to make it public.
and this is Christine Molis,
Melba Coody's daughter,
who was really instrumental
in getting the photographs
on display in the Bullock,
and that's me.
And then we also had a history harvest.
We collaborated with
UTRGV Special Collections
to give a workshop to UTRGV students
on how to digitize photographs, documents,
and how to conduct oral histories,
and so that was my part.
And we also, in terms of
the spirit of collaboration,
this is Valerie Ramirez,
and she's a member
of the Hidalgo County
Historical Commission.
And so we had support
from local universities,
from the archivists, from the students,
but also from the local
County Historical Commission.
And in this case, the
County Historical Commission
was really supportive,
but they also are not always tech savvy,
so figuring out how to fill
out the application in the PDF.
They also had a president of the,
the Chairman who was hospitalized.
And so you know this is all volunteer,
and so this ended up being
a tremendous opportunity
for collaboration.
And so I'm hopeful about the future
and possibilities for making public change
through engaged public history work,
but I'm also painfully aware
of the climate of this work.
So most people know about Hidalgo County,
or places like McAllen because of
it was ground zero of family separation.
In every county where we are
unveiling historical markers,
there are multiple detention
centers for immigrants.
You know, I wrote in
the epilogue of the book
also makes direct parallels
between the families
like Miguel Garcia,
who were literally searching the landscape
for the remains of his son,
and families today who
are doing that same work.
And so I'll just speed through here,
but you know, (mumbles) this
is a center for human rights,
and I am gripped by the roles of families
who are again preserving the
names of their loved ones
who disappeared when crossing
into the United States,
who are calling on the state
to remember the names and the
faces of their loved ones.
And you know, over 6,000
people have died since 1994,
and deterrence policies funneled
people seeking refuge in the United States
through the desert in Arizona,
and through the
treacherous parts in Texas,
and so literally in the
same counties in Texas
where loved ones were a hundred years ago
looking for the remains
of their husbands and
children and daughters,
families are doing the same work
of trying to identify the
remains of people who have died.
And so, so I'll stop there
to answer any questions that people have
about the public work, the history itself,
the recovery work, and look
forward to a good conversation.
(audience applauding)
- [Woman] So Stephen had to
leave, I'm taking over for him.
So would you like to field
questions, would you like me?
- Sure, I can field questions.
- Alright, thank you very much.
- Yes?
- [Sandra] Hi, my name is Sandra.
I really enjoyed the book.
Thank you so much for
what you're doing there
and (mumbles) outside of academia.
And I know you talked a
little bit about this,
but I was really struck by,
when you say vernacular history,
what you call it in the
book is politics of memory,
and I'm just curious how you--
- Oh, there's a microphone.
- [Sandra] Let's try it again, sorry.
- Yeah, so you were asking
about vernacular history making?
- [Sandra] The politics of memory.
- The politics memory.
- [Sandra] Yeah, I'm really curious how,
and was hoping you could reflect
on your graduate training,
and getting to this approach,
and understanding objectivity.
And I majored in American
studies, American history,
and so something I was really
enjoying about your book
was how you were sort of
pushing back against that
(mumbling).
- Yeah, well I think you know,
unfortunately there are still
a good number of historians
that are skeptical of oral history.
So you know, I intentionally
put that section
in the book in the introduction
about the possibilities of oral history.
I mean, we have known the
possibilities for decades,
(laughs) but I also thought that
people who maybe are not
historians might read this book.
And there's always a
sort of quick dismissal
of oral history as evidence,
and so I'm really interested
not only in studying memory
and in conflicting memories,
so the first chapter looks at
the the lynching of Antonio Rodriguez,
and really there are no
family members in that town.
He is burned alive at the
stake in November in 1910,
and he is understood to have
just been passing through town,
or have been a migrant laborer,
so he didn't have roots there.
But that lynching continued
to shape the racial politics
and society in the town
for over 100 years.
And so there are these competing accounts.
Was it justice in action,
did he really murder
Effie Greer Henderson,
or was he just a proxy, and
was it really somebody else,
and was it actually a brutal,
brutal immoral act of mob violence?
And so those tensions
coalesce in the town,
and they don't fall along racial lines.
And so that was something interesting
that I wanted to point out in the book.
That there are competing memories,
and they do different work.
And so the circulation of
an account of the lynching
by civil rights activists in
the 60s and 70s for example,
animated a particular kind of organizing.
That young Chicanos and Chicanas
were imagining themselves as responding to
long histories of violence
and discrimination.
And so sharing that
story helped to mobilize
a certain kind of
awakening or consciousness.
And in another context,
sharing that account warned
a Mexican sheep shearer
not to have relations
with white women, right.
That even proximity to
white women is dangerous.
And so I was interested in what kind of,
like when did people
decide to share this story,
and what was the lessons
that were being conveyed.
But also, how is it that 100 years later
people were still remembering this event?
But then I also as a historian,
for people who think that
memory is not serious work,
interested in using oral histories
for what they expose in archives.
And so for the Porvenir
massacre, for example,
if I hadn't conducted the oral
history with the Alvarados,
I would not have found the court case
that was filed by the widows in 1926.
And so 12 survivors of that massacre
filed a claim against the US government,
which led me to other
cases of Mexican nationals
that had filed cases
against the US government
seeking indemnities.
And so it led me to a legal archive
that historians hadn't found.
And so, so part of the work,
so there's the study of memory itself,
and then there's the use of oral histories
that point you to archives
that haven't been analyzed.
And again, thinking about the work
of Norma Longoria Rodriguez
to prompt me to ask different questions.
And so I think that the work,
and the importance of
oral history is multiple,
and it just takes,
if you pull together the right committee
that understand the
politics of the questions,
so I was taking classes with Alicia,
who was thinking about how is
it that people seek justice
in the face of negligence by the state.
I was thinking about (speaks
foreign language) for example
and that what is the work
that women were doing
just showing up publicly to mourn.
And so that helped me ask
new questions as well.
But it also helped me engage
just questions of what does it mean
to take on the question of what is loss.
What does it mean to analyze loss?
And so I really was
working with historians
and people in cultural studies,
and building this
interdisciplinary project,
but I had a committee that understand
the politics of the work and
the urgency of the questions.
And so I think part of it
is finding the right methods
and articulating the methods
that help you answer the
questions that feel urgent to you.
And sometimes it maybe
just means pulling together
the right group of people.
Joanne Meyerowitz, from what I know,
unless she's had this
whole other life before,
wasn't studying the borderlands,
but she could understand
having a feminist praxis
for our doing archival work.
And so I think it's,
I had this really excellent
synergy with my committee.
But it's an important question.
- [David] First of all,
thank you Professor Martinez.
My name is David, and I'm
actually from Brownsville,
so this is all very
relevant to my upbringing.
But I'm aware of how Brownsville
and South Texas are now
as demographic wise,
but what does Brownsville
and South Texas look like
in 1910 to 1920 when this
violence is happening?
What's sort of the distribution
of the demographics?
Is it, I suppose what
percentage of Mexican immigrants
are there living in these areas?
- Oh the question of percentages.
I'll have to send you the numbers of that,
because I don't have it offhand,
but in terms of the, the
demographics are changing.
So you really have by 1904,
the railroad arrives in Brownsville,
and it brings with it Anglo migrants,
you know Anglos who are
coming from the south
and who are coming from the north
who are bringing in new ideas
about race and racial hierarchies.
And so there had been a longer effort
to remove a Mexican land-owning community,
but also Mexican residents,
many who were American citizens
who were also engaged in
politics and in voting,
who were engaged in
educating their children.
And so you have this,
what was introduced as,
historians called the Juan Crow,
bringing Juan Crow laws
of racial segregation to South Texas.
And so that included segregating
children from schools,
prohibiting interracial marriages,
banning ethnic Mexicans from
participating in juries,
and also using racial intimidation
for disenfranchisement.
Also passing things like poll taxes.
And so there was this effort really
to create this new racial hierarchy.
And when laws and implementing
laws weren't as effective,
especially in trying
to displace landowners,
then racial violence was used.
And so the common phrase in this era
was you don't buy from the
husband you buy from the widow.
So you murder the husband and
then you intimidate the widow,
and you then take land that way.
But there's, what's happening
in terms of the shifting economy
is that this migration of Anglos
changes the way that land is used.
And so Texas changes from a
primarily ranching economy
in South Texas to a farming economy.
So it's also been described
by David Montejano
as the farm colonization of the Southwest.
And so you see that the
change in the use of land,
but also Mexicans move from being
members of the landed elite
to primarily being wage laborers.
And so it's a shifting of
the racial hierarchies.
Now of course it's important to remember
that this is, there are layered
histories of colonization.
So Antonio Longoria, for
example, has his land,
can be traced back to a
Spanish land grant, right.
So there are histories
of colonization that,
and the patterns of policing
that targeted different
racial and ethnic groups.
Some of the Texas Rangers
that are in this hall of fame
are celebrated for participating
in massacre and genocide
of indigenous people in Texas.
Some of them are also celebrated
for being slave catchers.
I mean, I'm not exaggerating,
they describe people as slave catchers,
and promote that in their bios
of some of these Texas Rangers.
And so it is a place
where the history of
genocidal colonization
and the history of slavery
and the history of US
empire and nation building
are all colliding, and in
the early 20th century,
you see these tensions being
targeted at ethnic Mexicans.
It's a complicated era,
but the numbers, I'll
have to send them to you.
- [David] Thank you.
- [Fernando] Hello, thank you so much.
My name is Fernando.
I loved your book.
Could you please speak to
the section on Dairy Queen?
I just thought it was so phenomenal
how it's such a public space,
and yet like the way that
you unpacked the history,
and how photographs there
have normalized violence,
just what that experience was for you
seeing that as you were
working through this project,
as you were writing it as well.
And then also a broader
question just about capitalism
and how it influenced, like is this,
could it be conceptualized this work
as like a history of capitalism
as postcards are printed
with people dying or
dead on the postcards.
How does violence become
a form in which capitalism
grows or is perpetuated?
- Okay, those are great questions.
Well, I mean to talk about
the Dairy Queen briefly,
you know it was an eerie experience,
so I was driving home to
see my family in Uvalde
because I had been doing archival work,
and then I stopped in a Dairy Queen,
which is you know, on these road trips,
you need to go to the bathroom,
you need some iced tea,
and so Sabinal is not too,
you know maybe 20 miles
from where my parents live in Uvalde,
but anyhow, so there was a Texas Ranger,
a photographic exhibit
honoring the Texas Rangers.
And so it included
photographs of a lynching.
And so it was this moment,
I had been conducting archival work
on the history of anti-Mexican violence,
and this was one of those
other moments, you know.
Talking to Norma Longoria
Rodriguez and having pie with her
was one of these moments.
Talking to the Alvarados in Uvalde
about the Porvenir massacre,
and hearing about the conversations
where they had talked to the local county
about having historical
marker, and been dismissed.
Or traveling to archives
and seeing archivists
pull documents out of the
folders that they requested.
There were these other moments
where I thought that the
need to study oral history
is also about studying the politics
of how history is produced,
and what who it's serving,
and who is committed to
protecting a version of history.
How is power, memory, and
history all coalescing.
So this Dairy Queen exhibit
with these lynching photographs
for me is a really profound example
of the kind of racial intimidation
that people are exposed to.
So for people who identify with
victims of racial violence,
who say that might look like me,
or that reminds me of
somebody from my family
who was treated that way,
that is the kind of image
that reminds you of what your place is.
But they're similar, it's
not a lynching photograph,
but also you know the
the wrought iron signs
across the state you know
it's like Texas kitsch,
you know we don't call 9-1-1,
and it's got the Colt
44 revolver, you know.
It's like metalwork, and
people put them on their homes,
and shops have posters that say
we don't call the police,
we prosecute shoplifters,
and it's got people on a
scaffold before being hanged.
And so these kinds of images,
I was really struck by
not only the way that it had been curated,
because there were no captions,
you didn't get the sense of
this could have been in Sabinal,
it could have been anywhere,
we didn't know who the victims were,
but the way the kind of
work that it was doing,
and talking to the
women that worked there,
saying things like I don't
like to take out the trash
because I don't want to
look at those photographs.
But also that the person
who curated the exhibit
was so happy to talk about
the Texas Rangers, right.
So he was part of creating
reenactment groups,
and celebrating this era of
Texas Rangers in particular,
from like the 1880s through the 19-teens.
And so it was also then an experience
to try to give space for thinking through
what is the interest in somebody
in these reenactment groups
in creating these the celebration,
and being a part of participating
in vernacular history making.
You know, not to dismantle
these mainstream narratives
but to reinforce them.
And especially in rural communities
where people don't have access
to cultural institutions.
The Dairy Queen is what you do.
It's where old men drink coffee.
And so I was really interested
in how these politics play out in ways.
I mean, it's racism in plain sight, right.
So people think about monuments,
Confederate monuments coming down,
but this is another history
that is just celebrate
without because most people
don't know this history,
or they do and they really do
think that this is progress.
They really do think that Native Americans
in this era were savage.
And so for them this is,
they're honoring Texans
that helped to build the state.
So that's interesting.
You had a second question though.
- [Fernando] Yeah, about like,
like if can your book be told
like in, like a history
of capitalism in Texas.
- I think so.
I mean, certainly if you,
I mean if you're thinking
about the commodification of,
I mean the ways in which
racial violence was also used
to suppress union
organizing, labor organizing,
and also to intimidate a
vulnerable labor force, certainly.
I mean, there's a long
history of Texas Rangers
and border patrol being used
to suppress efforts for labor rights,
or also just to you know
deport laborers before payday.
So there's, the history of
policing is deeply interconnected
with the exploitation of labor,
and the recruitment of vulnerable labor,
and then the exploitation of that labor.
But in the terms of the
commodification of the postcards,
certainly, it's a, there's a history,
you know, the history of
photography in this era.
There's the use of, I
describe it as the convergence
of wartime photography,
the photographers that
are taking photographs
of the Mexican Revolution,
but also of the development of this,
the sell of these postcards as souvenirs.
So it's a way that you
create not only a market
that celebrates this kind of
dehumanization in photography,
but you also see the wider circulation
of the criminalization of Mexicans.
And so you see the figure
of the Mexican bandit
taking root in Texas,
but then also change,
creating a national figure
of the menacing Mexican that
we are still living with today.
So this was not just the postcards,
but also the political cartoons,
and in another version,
when I've given talks to
bigger public audiences,
I show some of those political cartoons.
It's this moment when you
see the crystallization
of Mexicans as bandit,
as foreigner, as threat
being cemented.
- [Woman] We have time
for one more question.
- Oh there's two, so maybe you both ask,
and then and then I'll
combine them really quickly.
- [Larissa] Thank you.
Okay, so my name is Larissa.
Thank you for your talk.
I mean I think this is
really important work.
But yeah so I guess my question
is where do we go from here?
Like I think it's really
interesting that you chose Texas,
and then like this, I just
think it's sort of ironic
considering Texas is also like,
like produces text books,
and it's like a lot of,
yeah it's like missing
so much information.
And so I guess, I don't know,
what role do you think
that books like yours
can play in teaching
more of the community,
and how do we make those
things also accessible?
Because I know a lot of times
academic papers are written
for people in academia,
and so it's, yeah, like
sometimes it's really hard
to then go back to like for
example rural communities,
and try to just be like,
no actually, all that
they taught you was wrong.
So how can you really
have engaging dialogue
where people can start seeing,
yeah, like seeing this without also,
I mean the history is really violent,
and I can, yeah, and also even like
how do you begin teaching
children, like at what ages,
but I don't know.
- Yeah, these are really
important questions,
and these are some of the questions
that I don't have all the answers for.
But you know, one of the
things for Refusing to Forget
that I started to do, you know,
one of the things was to build a,
yeah quickly ask your question.
We'll talk at dinner.
Okay, we have time, okay.
So really quickly though.
But it was to write a
part of the public work
for Refusing to Forget, as I
brought students on at Brown,
a group of graduate students
and undergraduate students
and we wrote a curriculum,
four-day curriculum on Jovita Idar.
So again, how do you
tell this brutal history
of racial violence to children,
which is not my, that's not my skill set.
But so we developed this lesson
plan, and it can be modular
so that teachers can use
different different parts of it,
but it gives a history
of this racial violence,
a history of the Texas
Rangers, and the brutality,
but it also gives the
history of Jovita Idar,
who not only was a journalist
who literally stood in
front of the Texas Rangers
to try to keep them from
burning down a printing press,
they eventually burned it down,
but before they did, she also
wrote these newspaper articles
documenting the atrocities.
She also organized for women's suffrage,
she also organized for access
to public schools by
these Mexican children,
and she also helped build
the first cross-border
civil rights conference
(speaks foreign language)
And she had, and she organized
a women's conference alongside it.
And so it was this conference
that invited people from
both sides of the border,
because in this era there
was not really a border,
people moved fluidly back and forth.
And so she imagined civil rights
organizing in a fight for social justice
having to be a cross-border coalition.
And so bringing these sort
of radical calls for justice,
bringing a figure like Jovita Idar
to a public audience, to an
elementary school audience,
to me was a really
captivating opportunity.
And it's something,
we matched it up so it fulfills the TEKS,
knowing that every student
in Texas in public schools
has to take Texas history in K through 12,
and if they're a university student,
they have to take it again,
that's a big group of students.
So making it fulfill the requirements
that a teacher would need
to teach that in a Texas history class.
Now, you know my parents
walked out of schools in 1970
to protest discrimination
and segregation in schools,
and one of the things that they demanded
was Mexican-American studies
be taught in public schools,
and finally in 2019,
it's going to be offered
by teachers and school
districts that support it,
but students can get state credit
for taking Mexican-American studies.
And so I'm part of a group of historians
that are just hustling to try
to help develop curriculum.
And so Arlinda Valencia,
who is a descendant of
the Porvenir massacre,
has written some lesson plans
about the Porvenir massacre,
and so we are working really actively
to figure out how you
reach a younger audience.
I paired up with Professor Chris Carmona,
who just wrote a book called El Rinche.
It's a piece of fiction about this era,
but it's for young adults.
So there's, that is an active effort.
But I think that having the
historical marker is one thing,
having the book is one thing,
but then how you actually
activate the history
to shape and change public understandings
of the border and of immigration.
You know, my sister is an artist,
and she says the border,
people know the border
as a place of horror,
but it's, she knows it as a place of hope.
So we need to get back there.
- [Woman] Thank you, I like the
way you answer the question.
I was gonna about the
(mumbles) oral history,
and that role that oral history allows
academics to not only
produce academic research,
but also leading to public history,
and how that takes place
for you as a historian.
- Yeah, I mean, I think part
of it is that there's just,
for me, I think that as a historian
or people who study
histories of racial violence
that once you have
learned these histories,
and once you are starting to help
document these histories for
publication, for academic work,
that we have a moral obligation
to make sure that it's
available to a wider public.
And so and I also felt a moral obligation
for these families who had been working
to try to make these histories
public for over 100 years
to leverage my PhD to
do some of that work.
So you know, and we've received
a considerable amount of
resistance most recently.
And I am still concerned.
There's still a lot of good
work that public history can do,
and I'm very hopeful,
but I also now see that
there is possibility
for some of these efforts to create harm.
And so for a descendant
of the Porvenir massacre
to read you know local members of a county
describe their family members
as bandits, and as rapists,
and to say awful things
in public correspondence,
or to describe them as militant Hispanics,
the progress that we
have made is invaluable.
But again, it's about recognizing
that the urgency for
making this history public
is because we are living
in a violent context.
We are living in another era
where troops are being sent to the border,
where immigrants are being,
where people who are seeking refuge,
asylum seekers, are being imprisoned,
and where there is a rise
of white supremacy and racial hate.
And so in this era, we have
had some very good luck
finding partners and allies in the state
to help have a truthful accounting
and to show real leadership,
but I'm also seeing that now,
as some of these events
have become more public,
and we've received more attention,
that there is now an active
effort to stop the progress.
And so in some cases,
it has exposed a a
troubling part of Texas.
But I'm more determined than ever.
So the book is out.
There's nothing they can do about that.
The marker is up, (laughs)
nothing they can do about that.
So you know determined to
keep making more progress.
- [Woman] Please join me
in thanking Professor.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
(calm percussive music)